con el estallido de la guerra en ucrania
cientos de miles de personas han huido
de su país buscando un nuevo hogar en
algunas de las naciones vecinas según la
onu hasta el momento polonia es la que
más ucranianos ha recibido con más de 12
millones de personas refugiadas
tuve mucho miedo durante todo el camino
porque leí que muchas personas
recibieron disparos cuando intentaban
salir de la ciudad y ser ni big es una
de las ciudades donde hay disparos
masivos fue realmente aterrador
[Música]
en segundo lugar hungría ha dado la
bienvenida a más de 200.000 personas la
mayoría niños y mujeres que ahora
esperan encontrar trabajo para poder
salir adelante en un país extranjero
cuando un estábamos en casa sabíamos de
los puestos de trabajo en hungría y que
conseguiríamos trabajo aquí también
existía la posibilidad de ir con un
familiar a alemania pero hungría está
más cerca
también eslovaquia y rumanía han
recibido a una gran cantidad de
ucranianos más de 99.000 y 85.000
respectivamente en ciudades como
superaba a los hoteles se han convertido
en refugios para migrantes con decenas
de voluntarios dispuestos a ayudar
hasta ahora desde que la guerra empezó
hemos acogido a unas 3000 personas aquí
en las habitaciones en el gran salón de
baile en esta sala y también en mi
despacho
office en medio de la crisis de
refugiados la onu advierte que el éxodo
será aún mayor y mientras las naciones
vecinas además de dar refugio a los
desplazados mandan mensajes y pedidos de
paz